-Our next guest
is a very talented actor
and comedian you know
from shows such as
"The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel"
and "Search Party."
His podcast, "Dead Eyes,"
is available
wherever you listen to podcasts.
Please welcome to the show
Connor Ratliff, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hello, Connor! How are you?
-I'm great.
How are you doing?
-I'm doing good.
We have been
in the same room often.
You've actually been in sketches
on this show
that we filmed
outside of the studio.
But this is the first time
we're meeting,
and I'm very excited about that.
-I'm very excited, too.
It's very nice to meet you.
-But I have also -- You have
a talk show of your own.
-I do. I do a show called
"The George Lucas Talk Show."
-Yep.
-I pretend to be retired
filmmaker George Lucas
and interview real people
as themselves, yeah.
-And this has been something
that's been shared
with me a lot.
You have a pillow,
a "Late Night with Seth Meyers"
pillow on the set of the --
-Yeah.
-There you are as George Lucas.
-Why do you have my pillow?
-You were doing South by
Southwest, and I was also there.
And we were --
I was starting off the show
around the same time.
And I had lots of --
The set was decorated
with talk-show paraphernalia
from other talk shows
to establish that "George Lucas"
was among the pantheon
of talk-show hosts.
And so we stole
one of your pillows.
-Yeah.
-You had this display that had
all these pillows at South by
Southwest, and you had so many
that we thought,
"They won't miss one."
And I actually thought,
you know,
probably these other pillows
will end up in a landfill,
and we will actually protect
this Seth by Southwest pillow.
-I think that's probably
the most likely outcome.
In the end, I don't know
where any of those pillows are,
but it's a huge part
of your show.
-Yeah, and the deal
has always been
anytime we've had writers
from your show as guests
on "The George Lucas Talk Show,"
we always say, "Tell Seth
if he wants his pillow..." --
Or George says it.
George says, "Tell Seth
if he wants his pillow,
he has to come on the show."
-Yeah.
-And the offer stands.
-I'm very excited
to get the pillow back.
-Yeah.
-I will be doing that.
You -- This is, I think,
very common in podcasts now.
It tries to solve a mystery.
-Yeah.
-But unlike
other podcast mysteries,
this is a very small,
tiny mystery.
-Yeah.
-And this is "Dead Eyes,"
and this is a story
that I had heard
before I knew much about you.
And tell people
what the mystery is.
-Okay.
So, in the year 2000,
I was a young actor
fresh out of drama school.
I was cast in a very small
speaking role
in the HBO miniseries
"Band of Brothers."
-A fantastic show.
-Great show. Great show.
-I was so excited
to be part of it,
and then I found out,
"Great news. Tom Hanks
is directing your episode."
And then the day before I was
supposed to film my episode,
I got a call, frantic,
from my agent's office saying,
"You have to get there
right away.
Tom Hanks has looked
at your audition tape
and he's having second thoughts.
He thinks you have dead eyes."
And so I had to go
and re-audition
in person for Tom Hanks.
And minutes later,
I was told they were deciding
to go another way.
-So this is -- Yes.
-[ Audience awws ]
-A very sad story.
-Very sad story.
-Yeah.
-Not only -- I think any actor
would dread being told
they have dead eyes,
but to get it from the person
who is considered the nicest man
in show business.
-Yes.
Like, if I had been cast
in a very small role
in "Eyes Wide Shut"
and then Stanley Kubrick
had said it,
I would have thought,
"Of course."
-Yeah.
-You know?
But this was the nicest man
in show business,
so I thought,
"Oh, I'm so broken as a person.
My eyes are so awful that
the nicest man in show business
couldn't even bear to have me
be the tiniest part
of 'Band of Brothers.'"
"With all the horrible things
that happened in World War II,
we can't show this
to the audience."
-[ Laughter ]
-Now, had you ever even thought
about your eyes
as being a detriment?
-No, I had plenty of bad things
I thought about myself,
but the eyes, I thought, were,
like, just fine, normal
human eyes.
-The eyes were great.
-Yeah, yeah.
And since, I've heard nothing.
It was the only time
I got that note.
-And so you decided
to do this podcast
to drill down because --
This was a very --
I mean, all jokes aside,
this was a very real thing
that affected you
and affected your relationship
with acting.
-Yeah, I mean,
if it hadn't been this,
it probably would've been
10 other things
that would've added up
to me deciding,
"I don't want to be an actor.
This feels terrible."
But I got it in one concentrated
dose of like -- Choonk!
You know, "You are broken
and cannot do this."
But I decided, you know --
I had never --
He didn't say it to me. It was
a message I got through...
-And, by the way,
I would say a better agent
would not have passed it
along to you like that.
-It was a complete breakdown
along every part
of the chain of communication.
-Yeah.
-I never should've been told,
"Here's what's going on."
They should've just said,
"You have to go in
and read the scene again.
He wants to meet you."
I would have been thrilled,
you know?
-You have a guest coming up
on the show that I would love
for you to announce now.
-Yes.
So, on March 10th,
for our 31st episode,
our season-3 finale will feature
my conversation with Tom Hanks.
-Now, this is thrilling.
-Yeah.
-This is thrilling.
-It's -- It's beyond thrilling.
It's -- It is, you know --
I didn't expect it to happen.
The podcast was designed -- The
podcast is about disappointment,
so I would be foolish --
It was baked into the DNA
of the podcast that maybe
we'll never get to him.
-Right.
-But we did. And it's great.
It's a -- We have a fully --
we hash out everything,
and it's everything that
I wanted from the conversation.
I would not have gotten
this conversation
if I had played the role.
-Right.
-There would never be a world
in which
I played this small role
and then 22 years later
I got to talk to Tom Hanks
for over an hour.
-Right.
-You know? So it's --
-Yeah, the guy who got
that part right now is like,
"What the [bleep]?"
"Here I am over there.
I got this light in my eyes."
-He's doing great.
He actually does --
He has a great career.
He does a lot of audio books.
He's doing fine.
-Alright.
I like that you've kept up
with him, as well.
-I have. He's a very --
I talked to him on the podcast.
A very nice guy.
He had no idea it had happened.
I actually found out when I
talked to him that the same day
that I was re-auditioning,
there was a second car
filled with alternate actors
who were ready to take my place
if and when I got fired.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-And now, obviously,
now you're doing the podcast,
so it comes up all the time
that you think
about this moment.
-Yeah.
-World events right now
might also make you think
about the part.
-Yeah, the character's name
was Private Zielinski.
And if you follow the news,
you might have heard that name
almost every minute
of every day now,
one of the most famous names
in the world right now.
-Right now.
The other thing
that is amazing to me,
even more amazing
than the fact that you got
Tom Hanks to do
your podcast, we --
Our research did some digging,
and you as a young man were --
You went to sort of a C-SPAN --
What was it?
-I was on, like,
a high school --
It was the senior year
of high school, went on a trip,
and I guess that's how C-SPAN
gets a lot of their
studio audiences.
It's just, like,
gangs of students.
They just go in here
and watch a C-SPAN taping.
And it was a debate
about Russia and Ukraine.
-So, here you are.
There you are on C-SPAN in 1992,
I guess, maybe?
-Yeah.
Yeah, end of '92, I think.
And I was determined
to get on camera,
so I asked a question
about the differences
culturally between
Russia and Ukraine.
And the Russian person,
she said,
"Oh, there's really
no differences."
We're all the same.
We're all one thing."
And the Ukrainian representative
was like,
"No, we are different."
And, I mean, you can see.
It's just, like,
such a call forward to, like,
"Well, this is not
gonna end well."
-[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-This was also --
It should be noted --
You're doing this podcast now,
but was this a story
that you told people
before you did the podcast?
-Yeah, I mean, for a while,
it was an embarrassing story
that I had to tell people
because I told everybody
that I was going to be
on "Band of Brothers."
So it was kind of like --
I would tell it reluctantly.
Like, "Why aren't you on
'Band of Brothers'?"
"Well, here's why."
Then when I started doing,
like, comedy at UCB
and I started doing
improv and stuff,
people would be like,
"So, what's your story?"
And I was like,
"Well, I used to be an actor,
and now I'm doing this."
And they're like, "Why?"
You know, I would tell people
within the first
10 minutes of meeting them,
you know?
Like, I'm finding out
as I do the podcast --
I would ask friends, "When did
I tell you this story?"
And they'd be like,
"Five minutes after we met."
-[ Laughter ]
-Because it just explained,
like, well, here's why I'm doing
improv in a basement for free,
because this is fun
and I don't like show business.
-And, also, I will say,
it's -- if it wasn't real,
it would be the greatest
beginning of an improv scene
of all time.
-Oh, absolutely.
Yeah, "Tom Hanks thinks
you have dead eyes"
is a great initiation to the --
The scene writes itself.
-The scene writes itself.
-Yeah.
-And I know the podcast
hasn't written itself,
and it's been
a lot of hard work.
But, man, oh, man, has it been
a fantastic journey
to listen to you talk about it,
and I cannot wait to hear
the Tom Hanks episode.
-It's gonna be great.
Thank you so much.
-Alright. That's Connor Ratliff.
Subscribe to "Dead Eyes"
wherever you listen to podcasts.